j'ai mis mon meilleur homme sur le coup
c'est luià vous êtes sûr oui dites
bonjour à mon
cousin on va se marier on va se marier
c'est la fin de Jover car ah
a c'est urgent faut que tu viennes tout
de suite quoi faut que tu viennes tout
de suite le compte de Neville un
promoteur ver il faudrait que quelqu'un
s'infiltre dans le château et vole les
contrats il faudrait que ce soit un
portugais tu vois parce que le compte il
négocie qu'avec des Portugais c'est qui
le Portugais qui va infiltrer le château
ah non ah
non je vous fais investir dans le
Beverly h portugais jeachète tout
j'achète là c'est pour ma belle-mère à
l'extérieur allez champag champagne ou
Marie ellisabeth comptesse de Neville
rez ça tout de
suite c'est quoi ces chens les contrats
sont juste là on D et puis on signe
excuse-moi il y a une erreur ce n'est
pas du sauter de veau c'est du sauter de
porort qui faut absolument que tu
répondes le n'arrête pas de me relancer
c'est urgent qu'est-ce qu'il fait là
quand il est content il
court com mon laborador ah tenez je vous
présente le nouveau major d'hom je suis
désolé V surpris
commissaire bonsoir ça vous amuse ma
femme
il faut annuler le
[Musique]
mariage je va crever moi c'est sû je
vais
[Musique]
crever
désolé j'ai invité du portug tout mes
respect madame la compesse mais c'est
qui vous portug c'est qui é disponible
je suis permis de ramener pe ten ou des
petits flans
non c'est pas des petits flan c'est une
recette enestr de Portugal ah enfin on
dirait quand même des petits
FLS